so I was going to take a poll first uh I
was just on the plane and it's really
hard to sleep on the plane when you have
overnight flight so um how many people
here like I was going to figure out how
people like to sleep so who sleeps with
a neck pillow when they
fly raise your hands one two
surprisingly
few I to who sleeps so my my preferred
style is head- on desk it's like bring
the little desk thing down kind of like
put your head on there it's really
cramped because I'm kind of tall but
well taller than they make the seats for
but so how many people is that one two
also two so I'm assume the rest of you
guys just like don't sleep on Flames or
never fly awesome it's like
okay awesome a very revealing graph of
our sleeping activities
collectively uh while flying to places
far away
um so oh I had another one maybe I
deleted it okay well uh kind of just to
see what people have a background in so
who who here is like used um Theo or
theano I'm not sure how to pronounce it
decent number of
people may like
20% if who's here has used tensor flow
also a popular one
nice who here is use
Cafe okay how about psyit
learn yeah it's very popular I've never
used pyit learn actually so I'm uh I
don't know anything think about it
um but okay so who who here has used
Caris all right so who here has used
none of the above and or just like saw
deep learning I was like oh deep
learning so cool so hype right now yeah
yeah that's why I would that's why I
would go to this talk too
um so uh yeah so I guess so in terms of
why people are here so who here is
interested in NLP tasks very
broadly me guess like 20
20 who here is interested in Caris
learning a bit more about
Caris like 30
30ish here like cing just like yeah keep
your hands down zero no one here and
what is python I assume everyone knows
what python is programming language
probably
awesome okay so everyone's interested in
Caris let's get
started um okay so so I was going to go
through a little bit of the like
introductory stuff actually if you guys
want to install this you can go
to um I have it
on is there
wi-fi
okay so I have it on
GitHub and you can download it and play
with it so there's kind of two parts to
this uh one part is I made a bunch of
python notebooks to kind of explain
stuff and the other part was a project
that I did with like actual data um
which is like I put it up in like Google
compute engine and hopefully if we get
enough time I was going to go through
how to do that too um personally I think
the like ideas are more more interesting
so like once you have the ideas you can
kind of build on them and um do whatever
you want but uh yeah it's also good to
see stuff practically so if you want to
go to this repository I put a little
short link so you don't have to type
everything out make it
bigger
is this
good goo. go pm8 P5 capital
P yeah so probably a good idea to
download it and um yeah the readme's got
all the instructions for how to install
it it's basically uh you make a virtual
environment and then install your
dependencies in the virtual environment
and the dependencies are just the you
know Caris and Theo and um
Jupiter oh who here chose
Jupiter nice yeah is actually uh I don't
know I sort of just got into it and it's
pretty
awesome oh did everyone get it by the
way
yeah okay so
um all aboard the Deep learning hype
train
um yeah uh so first we can so so deep
learning uh like any kind of machine
learning Pro problem is just like how do
you build a model that describes real
data right and that's kind of something
that everyone's interested in generally
and deep learning itself is is kind of
blowing up because there are certain
problems where conventional models don't
describe it very well so um the
canonical examples are like vision for
example or
um audio processing because those are
very highly nonlinear tasks so by by
that I mean um like with vision the
thing that defines a cat is very you
know it's a very wide space of stuff and
um Because deep learning is
a I don't know I might offend some
people here but it's like brain inspired
uh it can model things that people model
well so um yeah so it works very well uh
hopefully I don't have to convince
anyone that it's a good good uh thing to
invest your time learning if you're
already here um but and also the math is
more or less the same for everything so
if you don't have any math background
we're we're I'm going to go through that
a little bit right now
so
um the the usual example for why deep
learning is useful is for building a X
or function so suppose you want so um
suppose you have you know a graph and
you want and you're trying to say you're
trying to map points to like true or
false and you have a point 0 0 0 one 1 0
one one and you want the 0 0 and one one
to be true and the one Z 01 to be false
right so in a conventional model you
know you can it's a a linear linearly
non-separable problem so what that means
is you can't draw a line through the
points and have one side of the line be
true and the other side of the line be
false right so so everyone following
that um so for example um what's the one
the the one that's not deep learning but
sort of like it Andre andrewy does
anyone
know no it's uh the support Vector
machine sorry so support Vector support
Vector machines are are useful for
solving linearly separable equations and
there's tricks to get around the the
problems of linearly separability but um
in practice you know uh linear
separability is it's not like support
Vector machines are are very linear and
they're not very good at interpreting
things like Vision which have like a
very nonlinear like Subspace of like
yeses and NOS like if you're have a cat
from this like huge number of points
that's a very nonlinear set of points
you can't just draw a line and say
everything on this side's a cat
everything on the other side's a dog or
something so yeah so that's the that's
the motivation for deep learning and uh
kind of the hello world of this is to
build a simple function that uh or build
a simple model that computes xor
function or recognizes an exor function
because that's a linearly
non-separable or nonlinearly
separable yeah so let's get started um
first we go ahead and import Theo and
theo. tensor um numpy and time for
benchmarking stuff
um next we can go ahead and Define our
data so this is just what I was saying
before so X is the input variable and Y
is the output variable so um you see 0 1
1 0o should go to zero false and 0 0 one
one should go to one it's true um does
everyone understand kind of why that's
not linearly separable or why that would
be hard for a kind of conventional
machine learning problem to to
solve yeah
cool um and feel free to ask questions
Anytime by the way I guess that's sort
of a expectation but yeah so next we're
GNA make a randomizer and uh this is
kind of the Crux of uh how do we build a
our machine learning model
um so first we we need to instantiate
the weights for our model so um a basic
deep a basic feed forward neural network
because everyone heard that term before
feed forward oral Network it's means
that you have your inputs and you
multiply them by a matrix and then you
add a bias vector and then you apply a
nonlinear
function so um first when you multiply
when you multiply by The Matrix those
are kind of the neurons um the neuron
activations are defined by The Matrix
weights and the bias Vector just means
that if you feed in a vector of all
zeros you don't get zeros out um and
then you apply a nonlinear function and
the non linear function is very
important for this problem of
non-separability because without it if
you stack multiple you know Matrix
multiplications on top of each other um
that reduces to one matrix
multiplication unless you have the
nonlinear function
right um and I don't understand very
well why nonlinear or why
different functions do what they do but
it kind of just works um magic um so
yeah so here we're going to initialize
our weight Matrix and our bias vector
and it's a good idea to initialize the
weights with kind of random noise um and
it's a good idea to initialize the bias
vectors uh with all zeros and so we're
going to get two matrices and two bias
vectors the first W1 B1 are going to be
our first layer of neurons and the
second one are going to be the second
layer of neurons right so this is kind
of what it initialized to to start off
with those are the the neuron
activations or the parameters of our
model okay um so this is the heart of
the network uh we get output the output
of our Network work will be
from uh first we do our dotproduct of
our input Vector with the the first set
of weights at our bias vector and apply
a nonlinear
function um the reu function is
basically if it's less than zero make it
zero if it's greater than zero it's the
identity
function um and then once we have that
output so this will be a the output of
this will be a vector we want to dot
that with a new Matrix the second set of
Weights add another bias vector and then
apply another nonlinear function so the
sigmoid function basically is a
squashing function so that it puts all
everything between zero and one um it
kind of looks like this so that's
another nonlinear function so um that's
basically all there is to making a
neural network um now we've got those we
can go ahead and try to Define what
we're trying to learn so in this case
we're trying to learn values for W1 B1
W2 and B2 so that the output of the
Matrix is close to the output that we
want
um and uh this is this is is a mean
squared error for calculating the the
cost function and we want to minimize
the cost function so if we minimize the
cost function it'll be close um and so
we can make these updates and the update
rule that we're going to make is for
each parameter W1 W2 V1 V2 we want to
change its value so that the gradient of
the cost with respect to that parameter
goes you know it it makes the cost go
down so we push it a little bit in the
direction that makes it go down um yeah
and that's how we learn that's all there
is to a neural network so everyone
pichen yeah so let's make our so you
know make our training function and our
test function um the training function
uh has update rule updates equals
updates and the test function outputs
our cost so we can kind of see how well
we're doing so how close are the output
values to the values that we want
so and let's go ahead and run that and
uh it runs pretty well so as you can see
the cost before training the network is
maybe like 0.47 and the cost after is
pretty close to zero so it learned the
model pretty well
um actually maybe we can try
like uh make a function to
predict the input
I don't know if this will
work
no let's do
this um no X is a shared variable which
means it's already kind of like we can
provide inputs this is kind of a weird
formulation for the problem
um oh well I should have done it
beforehand
but there you go um anyway so that's
Theo and that's how we build an neural
network in Theo so who's who here is
this like the first time thinking about
that or doing that nice so how confusing
was
that very confusing very confusing um
fortunately there's Caris which is
better yes uh so Caris I mean Caris is
maybe like an abstraction of of Theo so
like we have we have our model that we
just defined a two- layer neural network
that we've got all this math going on
behind the scenes um I mean I don't want
to understand math because I do computer
science is a python conference not a C++
conference um so uh Caris Caris is going
to make that a lot easier for us and um
that like for people who are kind of
into this stuff already and like oh
Caris it's I want to have more more
Hands-On control over it uh hopefully
I'll make a good argument for why uh
Caris we can still have a lot of control
over our models um and for people who
are like I don't want to understand all
this stuff you know car is awesome
because you don't have to understand it
you can kind of just build your model
see if it works it does a lot of stuff
for you yeah so so Caris is built on top
of Theo so like all the stuff that we
just did we'd like to combine it into
one thing so we don't want to have to
make our our weights here um we don't
have to want to initialize our layers
you know we kind of just want to say
give us a one layer uh give us a two-
layer neural network and train it and um
and we don't want to have to care we
don't have to put these like cost
functions in make the update rules stuff
like that
we just want it to be done for us um and
Caris does that
so um yeah so here we have the um the
input data again X and Y um and
now we uh we start building our model so
this is the same code uh that we did
before we Define an input
variable uh input layer we Define a a
dense layer that goes on top of it so
dense it just means that's a matrix
multiply and bias and nonlinear function
like
uh like this part would be a dense
layer
um and we can Define the activation
function so I put reu here but we could
change it
to the different activation functions
that you know of or look up sigmoid yeah
tan AG is another popular one um so yeah
so we can just plug our our reu function
in and we want to say five hidden
neurons so we have an input two input
Dimensions so we we pass it vectors with
Dimensions two and we have five hidden
neurons so it multiplies it by a 2x5
matrix and adds a bias factor of size
five and then we have another dense
layer that multiplies that output the
five dimensional Vector the hidden
vector by a 5 by one Matrix to give us
an output of one
dimension
um and uh there we go that's how we
build that model um super easy um don't
have to do all the stuff that we did
before and we can Define our inputs and
outputs here we build a model that takes
an input input
layer and gives us output the output
layer and we can compile it so that it
optimizes using you know we can change
the optimizer if we want but the
optimizer subgradient descent just
refers to this process here um so again
if you don't want to understand it you
don't have to understand it um but
basically different optimizers do
different things and we can experiment
with those um and the loss function is
the cost function that we used here so
like how do we Define outputs close to
inputs um um and uh this is a good one
this is a good way so mean squared error
is a good way to define outputs close to
inputs you might also
say um we want our cost function to just
be like y minus output because if y y is
close to Output then y minus output will
be zero or close to zero um there's
different ways to Define that but uh
again if you don't have to want to worry
about that don't have
to and lastly we can go ahead and train
it
uh yeah so a went down again so it works
so is this did this make
goe yes that is true um I mean it's it's
like a stochastic process right so you
can't you never really know like this is
going to work or not for for your your
presentation um yeah but it went down is
is the gist and uh
like I mean a lot of a lot of this is
like twiddling around to see what'll
make it go down the most what'll make it
go down the least um I tell my
girlfriend just like I play around with
numbers all day to make them smaller
because that's the easiest way to
explain it um you're you're trying to
make the loss get smaller so yeah
um
yeah so did that make a bit more
sense or is everyone lost
still great because it'll get a bit
harder from here um so Caris is still
very much an underactive development
because uh life is still under very
active development um and we want to uh
you know do cool things and sometimes
Caris might not support those things um
so a lot of what I was going to talk
about in this talk was how to make Caris
do those things um because you can and
that's what makes it a awesome framework
for developing stuff so um so first so
who wait raise your hand again if you
were interested in like natural language
processing or or language
modeling okay um so how many people have
heard of word
embeddings or word word
Tove word Tove or glove is the other one
I guess similar Concepts um they all
refer to the same thing and that thing
is how can we put our if we have our a
section A SE section of words maybe like
the Wikipedia Corpus or something how
can we learn a model that embeds each
word into a vector space and that Vector
space tells us something interesting so
um what I mean by interesting is is um
it figures out semantic
relationships so for example kind of the
canonical example is like
um you might have like the vector for
King minus the vector for man plus the
vector for woman gives you the vector
for Queen right so that's sort of a
that's the one that they used in the
paper describing word Toc I think um and
that's pretty cool like uh like that's
demonstrates a really high level of
understanding for uh a model that's kind
of untrained um and uh that's so so you
can do a lot of stuff with that so let's
talk about how to do that or like what
that
means and to do that we're going to
train a really easy uh task or like a a
trial task um so here okay so so word or
so word embeddings are used as an
alternative to like alternative way to
encode your your words in a vector space
um you might Define your vector space as
like 100 dimensions and within that
Vector space that's where all your
semantics are related so one dimension
might be like you know animal versus
human or something um each Dimensions
kind of tells you something about the
word um um and that's really not only uh
interesting like from a language view
but also saves computer space because if
you only have 100 Dimensions versus like
2,000 words 20 20,000 words um that's
very efficient um so let's look at the
alternative first the alternative would
just be to say for each word you know
let's make a if our if our ve if our
vocabulary is like 10 words we'll say
will make each word represented by a
10-dimensional vector where each
dimension in the vector represents
whether or not that word is the word
right so um the First Dimension might be
the the second dimension might be brown
fox jumps over the lazy dog um each
Dimension uh you either have a one or a
zero and there's only one one per vector
and that's called one Hoten coding so so
one hot dimension for each word
um yeah so there we go so everyone
understand kind of where this comes
from everyone
following so uh so the the one hot and
coded vectors each each Vector is a row
and there's one one per row and the one
refers to the word it is
right so uh so what's the problem with
this everyone have an
idea too many
vectors what lot of Zer a lot of zeros
yeah no way to associate overlapping
semantics right um yeah those are uh
exactly the problems and um like how
many words how many unique words do you
think Wikipedia
has I want to
guess yeah start with English language
50,000 maybe a bit
more actually I should Google it how
many unique words does
Wikipedia
have I I was going to guess like 200,000
but
is does anyone do anyone see it
okay yeah that's total words I I didn't
see number of unique words says million
a million okay we'll just go with a
million that's a lot of words uh and if
you had to represent each word as like a
million dimensional Vector um 32 bit
integer how many how many bites is that
it's a lot of bites um even for the
Cookie Monster
uh
sorry I was gonna take this
seriously okay so uh better better
approach is word embeddings which is why
I have this um and as we were saying
we'd like each Vector here instead of
being a bunch of one a one and a bunch
of zeros to be like have some
information about the semantics as
you're saying um like and also be
smaller um so we're going to train a
kind of toy example to do that type of
problem um so this uh I have a lot of
friends four friends who like have
certain colors associated with them red
or blue or red or green and um I have I
was like oh gosh I wish I had a way to
determine if my friend is red or green
from the sentences that I wrote about
them and
uh so yeah let's uh let's go ahead and
do that um so we'd like our we like to
figure out how to make word embeddings
that can tell us whether my friend Sam
is red or green so we can put together
some training data um for each sentence
we'll
say zero if red one if green so Hannah
not red she's green so it's one Hannah
is green it's one she's green uh Bob not
red also green um so we've got these
sentences and Ne next um we want to
split them into the individual words
because those are what we're trying to
embed um and we can make a convert from
word to index and index to word so what
I mean by index is when you build this
big
Matrix each row is going to be related
to a certain word so the index of a word
corresponds to that Row in The
Matrix um and I want to be able to
convert between rows and indexes or
words and indexes so that we can use
this um and train it
um so for example uh so this is all the
sentences converted so Sarah is
represented the zeroth index Sam is one
uh Hannah's two is three so this
sentence is the embedded version of Sam
I guess Sam is uh red
137 Sam is red so that's how we
represent a sentence as a a list of
indices and um now we can go ahead
and
um try to learn some embedding so or so
now uh this kind of tells us a bit about
our purpose so we've got three words per
s eight total words in our vocabulary so
eight possible indices 0 through 7 and
we want to embed it in a two-dimensional
space so why two-dimensional do you
think what yes so we can plot it that's
exactly why so so if we were doing
something like Wikipedia you know how
many dimensions would be a good idea for
that
task a
lot how many is a
lot is it
500,000 oh 500 or a thousand for a
million words h
um yeah so I guess anyone else want to
like guess
or I mean if you're interested in LP
what do you
think well okay the answer I was looking
for was it depends on the task so uh
yeah so we can't actually know but 500
2,000 is probably a good uh number for
for the task like kind of whatever task
we trying to do
um and uh I guess it it depends on the
things we talked about right like are
you constrained for
space um in which case lower Dimensions
is better are you trying to like is this
word embedding your your total model
like is it really important to have
really good word
embeddings or do you know do you not
have much data so you need to like make
a smaller Dimension to avoid like
overfitting the data or something
um yeah anyway so we're going to do two
because we can plot it easily um and
this is how we do that um so we'll
say um this is Caris again back to
Caris uh we have a input which is our
sentence and that that has shaped
sentence Max Lane um each sentence is
three three words so we want to have our
input shape via three dimensional list
or like three-word lists of
indices and cod is integers because
they're talking about the indices right
so um like it's going to look up in our
Matrix which row corresponds to which
word um and then we have our embedding
layer and uh the embedding layer is
basically like the Matrix
of all the words all the
uh all the vectors that represent each
word
um and then we have on top of that an
average pooling layer so don't worry
about this basically basically what
we're going to try to do is we're going
to try to train the model to make
the um the red people go
to sounds sort racist now that I think
about it but like the red
people go to um one or or zero sorry and
then the um green people go to one so
yeah so that's what what we want our
diens or our embeddings to represent is
whether or not the person is red or
green um yeah and uh so what everyone
following along here just going to kind
of gauge where everyone is on
this so um now that we've got this model
set up we'll go ahead and and predict it
and then print the vectors that it
learns so here we go um predict green so
we built our model that takes the input
sentence as input and outputs the color
prediction um and it we compiled it
using our subgradient descent Optimizer
and instead of the boss we used
before what mean squared error yeah so
instead of that we you're going to use a
different kind of loss called binary
cross entropy um binary cross entropy
just means it's either zero or one so if
it's a binary classification problem
binary cross entropy is a good one to
keep in the old nogin um and then we're
going to fit fit it so we're going to
run it for 500 or 5,000 EPO um given our
sentence data our our sentences and our
color desired color predictions um we're
just going to run that for 5,000 steps
and uh and then we can get the
embeddings as
the
um the the weights of this embedding
layer or the Matrix associated with this
embedding
layer and uh once we have that we can
for each person we can present or for
each word we can print the vector that
is that
embedded
right and
um yeah so that's really cool right
like does that make sense to everyone
no oh they they are all close to the
yeah the Lost went down um I think
that's kind of more has to do with uh
the way that we initialize the weights
rather than anything it wasn't training
to be zero but um yeah uh so let's go
ahead and plot those as was the purpose
for making this and it didn't work so
we're going to have to go to
the the plots that I made beforehand
because those actually
worked yeah so when we when we embed our
our di our vectors um Sam and Sarah so
Sam and Sarah were red and they're in
their own Corner in the vector space and
Hannah and Bob Bar Green they're in
all the other words are kind of there so
what this model is saying is we can
embed these vectors into a vector space
so that the location can kind of tell
whether or not that word is associated
with being red or green um
So based on these sentences like I
included like is not and red like not
like red can either be can either
associated with red or green but Hannah
can only be associated with red or with
green um just because of the way they
with sentences so you can't get any
information out of the is and and colors
uh it's just the people's names that you
want to worry about and that's what the
model figures out
so so that's word
embeddings does anyone have any
questions on on what we did
there
H
what what so yeah is there any meaning
to the
magnitude what is what do people
think
yes why
what what yeah what is the meaning I
don't
know how often how often often it's
coming so so so the pred exact model
that we're training is um
basically I'll go and talk about it
again um the model itself learns to make
the
embeddings such that the average over
embeddings is is close to zero if it's
associated with green close to one if
it's associated with red I
think
yeah
so um so if we have a a
sentence yeah so so this is close to
negative one I
guess and then this is a little bit like
offsets it a little bit so together if
you sum like
Sam Sam plus is red it would be close to
zero and if you sum Hannah plus is green
it would be close to to one maybe I
think that's the idea uh good question
any other questions about how we do
this so so this is very important for a
lot of natural language processing tasks
especially when we build a deep learning
model um because as we saying with
the uh dimensionality problem if we if
we feed a million ve like a million
dimensional Vector into a deep learning
model um you're going to have a bad time
because you know uh it's really hard to
not you know you want to start with some
idea of what the words mean in order to
build a model that processes them also
the speed thing is important you don't
want to do a lot of multiplication by
zero
um yeah so let's get into the heart of
it uh kind of change gears and focus on
another topic called recurrent neural
networks so who here has heard that term
before all right maybe 50% um does
anyone want to take a shot at what they
are neural networks for Time series
yeah how do they model time
series right connect the hidden States
between two steps so so we had our model
before that was we had a input and then
it there was a hidden layer and an
output um so if we want to provide
multiple hidden like multiple inputs
like a Time series of
inputs um and we want those to be
related to each
other um basically what we're going to
do is we're going to have a hidden state
that kind of changes each time we
provide an input and gives an
output um but it kind of it keeps
information about the previous input um
and all the the history so it can learn
these sort of time
dependencies um so anyone think they
might know why that's important for uh
language modeling task or why that might
be
helpful so you can understand the whole
sentence and sequence of
words the word of words matter matters
as opposed to bag of words so what might
be a example of
that what
if what
uh it is that's a good example is okay
not to come is not okay to come or
Grandma rode a train versus a train rode
Grandma also important instance of like
the order of words mattering a lot in in
the meaning um so a lot of uh a lot of
conventional natural language processing
algorithms aren't very good at capturing
these time series
relationships um so for people here who
are interested in NLP what kind of like
what kind of machine learning algorithms
do you use
typically late and deay Analysis so I
think that actually is supposed to
capture some semantics
right okay yeah yeah I can see that
um yeah it's a a bag of words model so a
bag of words model basically means um
like we represent a sentence as the
words that are in the sentence so like
that's what the um that's that would
confuse the sentences we were talking
about earlier because it doesn't know
the relationships between words
um it works pretty well for a lot of
stuff uh but maybe there's some stuff
and actually uh like a lot of this stuff
is pretty new so people are kind of
starting to see new P like things that
it might be useful for um what I'm going
to talk about later if there's enough
time is uh using that for answering
questions so
um like it's kind of hard to
model there's some some theory on uh the
order of words in a question matters in
terms of the answer we want to provide
um that's kind of intuitive to a lot of
people but before we were able to do
these sort of huge data sets with these
complex models um you know that wasn't
very popular like people were like oh we
can just say like what is the answer
answer to 6 * 7 um we can just represent
that as the words what answer 6 * seven
um so yes so so this is this is the
recurrent neural network um this is the
the diagram of the two layer neural
network that we did in
Theo um a oneto one mapping and we're
going to want to expand that to a
recurrence version which we have one
input maybe and then we want to get like
a Time series of outputs um say Ione
have an example of what uh that might be
like when when would we want to model
something that
way uh sorry
what the one to many
model so given one input have many
outputs what kind of
models might that be useful
for
okay one sentence might have multiple
meanings yeah that would be really cool
like that would be cool if you could
like give it a genre and it would like
give us a sample sequence of of that
genre is music like a Time series of
music yeah I wonder if anyone's done
that that's pretty neat um here's so you
can do all sorts of different kind of
recurrent neural network architectures
many to one might just be given a
sentence say if that sentence is happy
or sad um so sentiment analysis I think
um and then many to many models um
usually is for maybe mapping one
sentence to another sentence or like a
sentence to a like song or or something
like that you know time series to time
series um so now that we've got that all
easy squeezy I was going to go ahead and
devote a little bit more time to
actually understanding these and
building these yourselves so did
everyone get these
installed raise your hand if you didn't
get it
installed oh it's okay
okay so
uh yeah
so okay um so everyone have like a
python IDE that I want to work
in I'll go ahead and open
up so so um I'm in the directory that I
was uh just uh working or the directory
where I installed the
um
notebooks uh go ahead and activate the
virtual envir
environment this is really hard to see
too right
oh is that better probably
not okay can everyone see
now okay yeah so let's go ahead and
activate our virtual environment um and
we'll make a new file
called uh RNN
dopy okay
so so because I'm using python to I
always like to do the from
future import print
function um and let's import
Theo and from Theo import tensor as T
capital T this is kind of just a good
convention uh to do um and let's import
numpy as NP also uh conventional and
let's seed our random number
generator uh with uh the answer to the
life universe and
everything and uh make another random
number generator for using
elsewhere um yeah so um in
Theo um to do these Matrix
multiplications that are kind of at the
heart of our neural network
models uh we want
to uh be able to do those on a GPU
because gpus are really fast um and
really good at matrix multiplication so
Theo and also tensorflow and also Caris
provide a easy way to do that by
um basically abstracting it so um
because I'm not on a GPU the data type
here float X is float 64s but depending
on your GPU it might be uh 32bit floats
um is pretty standard
so yeah
um so once we have our model we want uh
it's it's very easy to just put it on a
computer with a GPU
and away it'll go much faster than it
would work on my laptop for
example um Okay and like we did before
we want to make helper functions to
create like to initialize our vectors of
or our matrices our weight
matrices um that represent each
layer
uh and so so when we say get weights um
this means we want to initialize a n in
by N Out Matrix so if we have an input
Vector that has Dimensions n
in um and we multiply it by a weight
Matrix like this then the output Vector
would
be
what it be an out right so um that's the
heart of the neural network and it's
it's pretty important to understand kind
of how we formulate this so what so the
way that we initialize these weights is
uh we want them to be random we want
random initialization so
um like that helps us ensure that when
we learn this model it's not going to
like all the weights are going to learn
kind of unique things about the model
they're not going to learn the same uh
values so if they're all the same
weights to start off with then it's they
probably will learn the same values it's
not going to be very interesting so we
want to add some Randomness in there um
and the the way we add the randomness is
uh kind of this strange
formula
um uh basically we want random numbers
between this value and the negative of
this value so let's create a numpy
array which is doing that
um
okay that's our W value um and then now
that we have a numpy we want to be able
to put it on um on uh Theo and Theo will
handle putting it on a GPU for us and
being able to do uh you know calculate
derivatives uh that numpy can't do that
um and Theo will also do a lot of
optimizations to help our model run
faster um
yeah so let's turn it into a Theo shared
variable
o we're just going to name it wcor
number of input dimensions uncore number
of output
Dimensions
um borrow is true so borrow is true
means is feno is going to just use the
memory allocated by
numpy um to store the The Matrix so it's
not going to copy the Matrix to new
memory um and strict is false is just
some extra stuff um basically strict is
false means we can multiply like a
like uh suppose we want we have a a
matrix of input vectors
like we can multiply that by our our
weight Matrix um or we can multiply
vectors by our weight Matrix
so yeah and uh return the feno shared
variable and we'll do the same thing for
the bias
function and uh unlike unlike with
weights it's usually a good idea to just
set your initial biases is all to zero
um I think there's like a mathematical
explanation for that but I don't know it
so
uh h i just ignore that um and again we
start off with a numpy array and then we
convert it to a Theo shared variable
borrow is true again and strict is false
again and return B okay
um so now we're going to learn our
Optimizer so um let's just try let's try
making this subgradient descent
Optimizer we were using before uh SGD
so SGD would maybe take cost and pram so
parameters that those are the parameters
that were learning in other words the
weights of the Matrix and a learning
rate
um and the equation which we had over
here is
uh
updates equals p p minus
learning rate time t. grad cost with
respect to P for p in
prams um and we can return
updates
so so our subg grading descent Optimizer
it's just going to calculate how much do
we change the weights uh for each each
time we give it data how much should we
change the rates the weights of the
model so that we learn something
useful
yeah so we'll come back to this later
because so subur descent um is just it's
one way to learn uh to change these
weights uh but there's other smarter
ways um depending on your model uh that
kind of can do more mathy stuff um and
if we want to make a really good model
um we need to take those into
account okay so let's also generate a
generic function for
testing
uh our model so if we have a model we we
have like n input Dimensions n output
Dimensions uh our input uh Theo variable
which is just a placeholder for passing
data um and our output of the model
um and then the parameters of the model
we want to make a function that'll just
be able to test that model on some dummy
data
so
uh okay so our uh our our testing
function will basically it'll make the
it'll calculates the updates oh I should
change this to our our subgradient
descent
Optimizer um it'll calculate the
updates uh and it'll create some de this
is just some some random data X datas
and Y datas are just random uh vectors
of of data for us to use and it'll train
the model to rep to to map the X data to
the Y data
um in other words it'll learn so
um yeah and this whole is just done here
some evaluation stuff for for doing
that now let's uh get into building a
recurrent neural network
um and
so so this is is how we we specify the
the network is going to be with
uh we have n input we have we set the
number of input Dimensions we set the
number of hidden dimensions in other
words the size of of this uh
Matrix um so each Arrow here represents
a matrix um so this this Arrow would
be uh n in to n hidden uh these arrows
would be n hidden to n hidden and these
arrows would be n hidden to N
Out
okay and
uh yeah
so uh let's see what we need to do for
this
first we want to have a variable
representing our
input oh before I
forget oh never
so we have a variable representing our
input data so this variable is just like
a
placeholder um when we said like Theo
does a lot of optimizations it needs to
know what it's going to be optimizing on
so we give it a placeholder that stores
the um like the data we hope to pass it
in this case we're going to pass it a
matrix um that's going to be like a
matrix where each row represents a input
Vector I think
um
oh okay um so the next part of the model
is as we were saying
before uh we
have um four or three different weights
for our vanilla Network um this weight
can everyone
see we have this weight the input weight
we have this weight the hidden weight
and we have this weight the output
weight um those are three sets of
matrices that we need to represent so
let's go ahead and use our get weights
function to represent
those so so for the WN is the input to
Hidden connections so that will be you
know if we have a vector with n in
Dimensions we get we m mly it and we get
a vector with n hidden
Dimensions um and those are the hidden
states of our
Network
um this is this will this Vector will be
or this Matrix will be the hidden to
Hidden connections so this is what's
going to help model the time series data
uh as these hidden to Hidden
connections um so on each time step uh
we take the previous hidden State and we
multiply like the the vector
representing the hidden state from that
we got from the last input we multiply
it by this hidden connection Matrix and
we get a new Vector representing the new
hidden state so and that that's
important because you know it'll help us
with these uh time series
data and finally we're going to have an
output Matrix that's going to be
uh it's going to be from the hidden
state that we have so we calculate the
hidden State and then we're going to
multiply by a matrix to get a number of
output
Dimensions
yeah and then we also need biases for
each of those
so oh we don't need a bias for the so
with the input State and the hidden
State what we're going to do is we're
going to multiply the input by the input
Matrix and we're going to multiply the
hidden State previously by the hidden
Matrix and we're going to add those two
together and we're going to want to bias
that sum so we'll just call that bias be
hidden and another bias function or the
other bias we're going to have is the
output bias
so
oh
um with uh for the output of the The
Matrix or the output of the
network and um we're also going to have
a hidden state to start the network so
um if we need to take the previous
hidden State at every time step what do
we do at the first time step uh we're
just going to have the hidden State
start at zero and then it'll do its
operations assuming zero is the previous
hidden state so that's
h0
okay and all the parameters uh the
parameters of the model are are weights
and our deves so W in W hidden W
out and B hidden B out and also we're
going to want to change the h0 of the
model so we want to learn a good
starting point for each um for our
Network like good starting hidden state
so we're going to want to we're going to
want that to be part of what we
learn and now let's define the
recurrence relationship so this is
really the heart of the network and this
was really tricky for me when I was
picking these up um this is going to be
where we actually Define what to do on
each time step so given an input X of t
and a previous hidden State h of T minus
one
let's say the new hidden State we're
going to apply our nonlinear tan
activation
function uh to the dot product of the
input Vector with our input connections
our input our input Matrix plus the
dotproduct
of our
hidden State pre our previous hidden
State dotted with our input or our
hidden
hidden to Hidden connections and we're
going to add our hidden
biases
um yeah so we're gonna add our the bias
on our hidden so so this is the how we
get a new input state or new hidden
State on each time step so does everyone
does anyone have questions about
this no
okay so now that we have our our
function to determine the new hidden
State Let's uh let's get the output from
that hidden state
so basically given the hidden State we
just want to apply a nonlinear
function um to the dotproduct of the
Hidden state with our hidden to Output
Matrix
right um and our nonlinear function in
this case will be a sigmoid function
so hft is our hidden and our W out is
our hidden to Output connections and
we're going to add our output
bias
um and uh lastly so now that we so this
this function step defines what we do at
each time step so we want to way to
apply that function to every step in our
input um and to do that we use a
function called theo.
scan um theo. scan returns kind of some
weird stuff but we want to basically all
we want to return well all we want is
the output of doing this operation on
every time
step
uh
so our our function that we run on every
time step is called Step uh the
sequences that we input are our X is the
the placeholder variable and uh outputs
info don't worry about this
um some boiler plate and uh we run it so
end steps is just uh the
number the number of steps to run the
function on so in this case x. shape
zero the First Dimension of X will
represent the number of time steps and
the second dimension will represent for
each time step that's the input
Vector so we have a x is a
matrix um the second one will be the so
the the First Dimension represents the
time and the second dimension represents
the
data and uh now let's just run our test
function
on uh the test function you wrot earlier
you can just run that on our Network
and cool
um so yeah so then we'll just test the
vanilla RNN and and uh say vanilla
because this is like the introductory
architecture
um so yeah so
python RN
n.p oops there's GNA be a lot of bugs
because I was using
Vim
um
oops I'm blame you guys for this because
uh she caught these while I was raing
it where is
that
o
this is should be called
tests non keyword
all oh
so right now a lot of what's going on is
Theo is making these optimizations and
storing stuff in the right place in
memory so we start off with calculating
the error the starting error is 15.
9745 or 48 uh and then on each time step
so after 200 iterations the um at
learning rate 0.1 so change the learning
rate on each like progressively but um
the error goes down to 10 and then two
and then kind of stops around there
so so the uh the function or the model
works pretty well um the eror goes down
the numbers go down which is pretty
cool
um yeah so does anyone have like kind of
talk about rnns and why like why there's
problems with them so Ione kind of have
an idea of why this model might not work
so
great
um so so what if the sequence is really
long
um so let's take a look at our equations
again and um get the idea of our update
rule is for each parameter we're going
to change that
parameter uh to minimize this cost so we
need to get the gradient of the cost
with respect to that parameter in order
to know how to change that parameter
right
um
so if we uh if we have a really long
sequence you know we have a like from to
get from this input this weight Matrix
here to this
uh output Matrix or this output that we
have like our we can calculate the cost
function up here and then we need to
figure out how does this cost change
with respect to this uh this weight
Matrix over here right
um and if our sequence is really
long what are we doing here we're doing
a bunch of Matrix multiplications
followed by a nonlinear function so if
we do that over and over
again um the amount that this
this uh Matrix actually affects the the
cost here it's going to it's going to
get smaller and smaller right
because like if we for each step apply a
nonlinear squashing
function um it's going to get
diluted uh like the the gradient is
going to get diluted so it's going to be
harder to say like how like how much do
we change this parameter
in order to get a a value of the output
that we want so that's the problem with
recurrent neural
networks uh in their basic form and
that's why I called this the vanilla RNN
um because we can do cooler stuff to be
able to get this to
work
um okay and uh before going into what
that cooler stuff is let's take a look
at the cost
function so right now we have our subg
grading descent
Optimizer uh that takes cost and the
parameters that we want to change to
decrease that cost and a learning rate
which basically like how much we want to
change change the parameters on each
step so instead of
using you
know like what this is saying is just
change the parameter
uh in the direction that
minimizes the cost with respect to that
parameter and change it a little bit by
the the learning rate um so there's
better ways to do this and one of them
is called rmsr Uh there's a whole list
of different things that we can we can
use for these
um but uh so RMS prop is one of them and
RMS prop um probably don't don't really
need to understand it too deeply but
basically what it's saying is um like we
want to make sure the gradients kind of
make sense for what they should be so
you know for each weight
Matrix you know we want to kind of
stabilize it so we're not changing it a
ton but we're not changing it too little
and that helps us uh helps the weights
learn faster so
um yeah so that's a that's a weight to
improve on the basic uh subg grading
design
idea and
uh so let's change our Optimizer to RMS
prop
um and I can just rerun it again see if
that makes it
difference again um like the numbers
will so so training neural networks uh
is difficult uh because um because of
this really nonlinear space that we're
trying to learn it's uh it's not easy to
train it so sometimes you might like
this like ideally RMS prop works better
but in this case the cost didn't go down
as much as just using The subgradient
Descent optimizer
so
um you know we can like if you're
building a neural network and um in a
production scenario it's a a good idea
to to want
to
um like uh try out a bunch of these
different optimizers to see what works
the best for your data and qu try it
quickly without having to write all
these uh these
functions anyway so so saying
um so so this is the the problem I was
talking about earlier um uh officially
it's called a Vanishing gradients so
that's just the problem of we can't like
we can't determine how much this
parameter affects our cost here as
easily because it's it the gradient gets
smaller and smaller as we go backwards
in time um and that's Illustrated here
so this is the RNN on the right and the
the noise kind of represents how big the
gradients
are um so I guess this is like 128 time
steps but after you know 20 time steps
the gradients basically disappear um in
other words at the start of the
sequence that like changing the
parameters at the start of the sequence
doesn't affect how much the the network
or how much the cost function changes at
the end of the sequence
um so in terms of modeling stuff uh
anyone see why this would be a
problem like give like suppose you're
you have a really long sentence what
what kind of problems would you run into
into with
this right you're effectively not paying
attention to the beginning of the
sentence um and that might be important
uh
so yeah
so there's better ways to do this U so
the network on the right is a
modification of this recurrent neural
network
architecture that will basically pay
attention to the stuff at the beginning
um and it's called long shortterm memory
it's very hot right now uh everyone's
doing it
um so you should too and uh and and
these are these are like the
descriptions of the two architectures in
comparison so so this is what we had in
our functions right we have a a hidden
State here that gets outputed that's our
hidden State and we take the hidden
state from the previous step we feed it
in we add it to the the new input State
we add those together and apply our
nonlinear function and then that gets
our our new hidden State and we pass
that along to to the next time step
right so it's a very this is basically
what the equations uh up here were
doing
um and uh our
lstm network is going to help solve that
basically by just being more
complicated
um we
uh we just add add a bunch of stuff and
and basically what these are adding is
they're Gates and what's that what
that's going to do is going to say you
know let's store the information from
earlier in the sequence and then let it
drip back into the sequence later on um
like like in in memory you might like
write to memory and then read from
memory in a computer science metaphor
sort of way
um and we're going to write to our like
storage unit and then we're going to
read from that storage unit and that'll
help make sure that the gradient with of
the cost function with respect to stuff
early in the
network is still there right because um
if we can store the the information from
the earlier in the sequence and just
like Loop it around to to the end of the
sequence and have that affect the the
cost you know that's going to it's going
to have a much more direct impact um so
that's so so you know without going too
much more into the math the idea is that
you can model long ter sequences with
like by paying attention to the stuff in
the start and um and these are the
equations for for doing that uh so so a
bit more complicated than the RNN
equations obviously but uh you know I
think if you if you wanted to learn a
bit more about this and kind of plunk
away at this uh these might start to
make a bit more sense um basically we
have a a forget gate and output gate and
the the forget gate just tells you like
so we have this this candidate state
that we're kind of storing from the
beginning and forget gate says like you
know how much how much should we swap
out the candidate State there be stuff
from from the beginning with stuff from
now like as we go through the time
series how much do we want to update
this state so we can turn off the forget
gate and then it's just going to keep
all this stuff from the beginning and
that's how we that's how we uh avoid
this Vanishing gradients
problem um yeah
so obviously a lot longer than the other
one
uh
but let's go ahead and comment that
out set no P or set pce
oops wait a
minute
um yeah so but basically it's the same
same formulas and same format so we have
our list of parameters for the so this
is just the weights and biases of the
network we have our different
you know all these different weight
matrices and bias vectors and we just
add them to this list of parameters that
we're going to store and we're going to
calculate how much the gradient changes
like the gradient of the cost function
um with respect to each of the
parameters and we're going to update the
parameters in such a way that the gr
that the cost function goes down in
other words our predictions improve in
accuracy and this is this is the step
function so at each time step we do all
this math stuff
um
yeah
um yeah so let's just uh try that
out so ideally what would happen if this
works correctly what do you think what
would
happen using the lstm instead of an RNN
what's what's going to
happen actually wait I'm going to turn
it off right
now decreases the error yeah why would
it decrease the
error yeah
exactly oops I need to plug
in
uh so again right now it's basically um
setting up our weights and putting them
into memory in the right place and
making
optimizations uh to help it run
faster and uh so so after lstms there's
another one called grus which is another
way of solving this gradient
um not super important to understand how
these work but uh yeah uh good good
reference uh and here's a testing
function for trying that out
um here we
go ah so it worked like it was supposed
to so remember our error was like
two-ish after the first training step
now it's gone basically to zero so the
LM has done a much better job at
modeling the the time
sequence yeah so last part is why do we
do all this if the talk was going to
Bear us basically uh it's to illustrate
like that's a lot of math and we don't
want to have to do that every
time um so this
code does all of that in Caris in like
way less m so we have our input like our
we generate some input data the same way
and then we Define our model you know we
have our input sequence going to be shap
like it's going to be uh input length
and input D so so the sequence length is
like the number of time steps and the
input Dimensions is the number of it's
the length of each Vector so each time
step has a a vector that's the size of
that Vector
um and uh and then we can literally
instead of having to do all that math we
can just say simple RNN specify the
number of output Dimensions lstm specify
the number of output Dimensions Gru
specify the number of output
dimensions and uh significantly easier
you know just one one line of code and
um we can test it out so the errors are
kind of weird here but um they you know
they just they learn
so so that's some R of that story
and so finally uh let's see how to
modify Caris so
um like cars is not uh like not
restrictive like you don't just have to
you know if you have this this types of
this type of network lstm network um how
do we build on top of it um and Caris
has got a lot of good support for that
and so talk about doing that I'm going
to talk about a popular application
right now which is adding attention so
making your network pay attention to
stuff and this was a really cool paper I
don't know if anyone can see
this
oops can you can anyone see that or
probably can't read this stuff if you
have it on your laptop then probably
it's easier to see but basically um if
you feed it in an image and you train a
network to write a sentence describing
that image which is really cool because
you know say you're like making a user
interface for helping blind people like
you could you know use some text to
speech thing that would tell the blind
person what the image is about
um along with a host of other uh ideas
and um and this is a bit of a
complicated architecture to try to build
build in Caris um because it's new and
uh you know Caris only develops gets
developed so fast but the way the
architecture works is we have this
sequence or this lstm that basically
goes through you know traverses the
image kind of in this way and then it it
pays attention to certain parts of the
of the image it's trained to pay
attention to certain parts of the image
image so the highlighted part I don't
know if you can tell but um this is a
picture of a woman playing a Frisbee
with her with her I guess kid um and the
network basically learns to light up for
the Frisbee so it's paying attention to
the Frisbee um so that when it writes a
sentence about that
image uh it can highlight like it knows
it's about of
frisbee
um
yeah so so this is a cool task and uh
attention is is one of those things
that's like very hot right now with like
startups and stuff I guess but um some
something that you know not easy to do
in Caris but we can do it and let's see
how we do that and to do that we're
going to have we're going to generate
some
sentences some uh sentences to model um
basic sentences like the Cat in the Hat
is in the barn the The Cat in the Hat is
in the house and then we're going to ask
questions so is it wearing the Hat um
we're going to say the the sentences
that are true for this are zero the cat
and the hat one The Cat in the Hat four
the dog in the Hat and five the dog in
the Hat um so these are all the true uh
answers to those questions um and we
want to train a network to say like
given a question and an answer is is
that answer true to the question right
um and so anyone have any ideas of like
you know real world application that
might be kind of like this
problem Google yeah
probably yeah type in a
question
Jeopardy online learning what do you
mean um yeah yeah yeah like automatic
assessing that's that's a cool one
um yeah Siri Yeah Siri is a good one um
yeah so all sorts of applications uh for
for answering this type of question
there we go text to speech
um yeah so these are the this is a
question and these are the answers that
fit with that question so is it wearing
a shoes Cat in the Hat in the shoes or C
the cat in the shoes dog in the shoes
yeah so this is our training
data and again we're going to want to
tokenize it and we're going to make a a
list of
vocabulary and um we want to use this
vocabulary to turn our sentences into
indices right like from our from our
impeding
um and uh this is our our vocabulary our
dictionary from word to index um so for
example wearing is is going to be Row
one in our bedding
Matrix
um next uh we just turn those into numpy
arrays so we encode and we have a
function for
encoding uh sentences as numpy
arrays um and we're going to want to
apply that to all our data uh and we get
something like this so 48 questions in
our training set um not 48 but like 48
question answer pairs
um this is our input questions our input
uh sentences and then why is the is
whether or not that sentence matches
with the
question and now we're going to get into
the Harry part of adding attention to
Caris so making Caris are lstms pay
attention to the stuff that we want them
to pay attention to um and this is
pretty cool so um our attention
mechanism will basically
say it's this part it's a given uh given
we have this Vector that we're want to
pay attention to so this could be we
encode the question and then we want to
pay we want the the lstm that's going
over the answer to pay attention to the
vector representing the
question um or use the vector
representing the question to decide what
words it's going to pay attention to in
the sent
sentence um and
basically um we get so each time step we
get a hidden State we're just going to
apply this uh way to like combine these
together and um and learn to pay
attention to certain stuff but what it
ends up doing is for each word it
increases or decreases the activation on
that word and um and that's going to be
important for uh determining which words
are like the the amount that the hit the
attention is active basically tells us
how important is that word or that's
what we want it to
do um and this is kind of a diagram of
so this is all the lstm stuff but this
part right here is the attention
mechanism so we provide an attention
Vector to our LSM and that uh that
modulates the hidden State over
time
and uh let's do that so uh this is all
the code for that
um I mean it's kind of a lot but if you
look at the Caris code base it's not
very much in comparison um but it it
basically wraps around the lstm layer
and modulates it uh you know it trains
it to use attention pay attention to
stuff um and then we generate our model
so our model is going to be input
sequences two input sequences the
question and sentence um we have our
embeddings layer again so we embed each
word in the question and sentence into a
uh 10-dimensional
space um because we don't have many
words we don't need that big of an
embedding vectors um and we apply the
question embedded and sentence embedded
we're going to apply that the embeddings
to each to the question and sentence and
then we're going to do something called
um or so then we're going to apply our
lstm
encoder um the lstm will basically read
in the
sentence and
output uh a vector you know it's it's
like
uh it's this type of model here um it'll
read in the sentence and output a single
Vector which is kind of the sentence
encoded um
so we have our lstm that we're going to
train on the encoder and we have our
attention mechanism that we're going to
wrap around the lstm that is going to
pay attention to the question
encoding so this
part
um and that's we're going to apply that
lstm to the
sentence so the sentence encoding is
going to depend on how we encode the
question and for our learning rule what
we're going to do is we're going to take
the cosine uh similarity between the
encodings of the question and the
sentence so
um so everyone kind of know what cosine
similar is between two vectors it's like
the angle between them so if the
questions if the question and sentence
match each other we want them to be like
a small angle and if they don't match
each other we want to be a big angle um
and this is just some U math saying that
idea
um and we're going to have our model
again we're going to use a RMS prop the
uh Optimizer that we had before um RMS
prop in particular works well for lstms
and and time series data and our loss is
going to be mean squared error
uh we're going to want to uh just set a
set a Target and we're going to you know
our loss is just mean squ error between
the Target and the
prediction so this is our these are the
this is the shape of our model uh none
means that that's like the batch so each
batch could be like you know you have a
batch of 15 samples or 100 samples none
is just a placeholder for whatever
number of samples you want 10 is the
length of the sentence
so uh each input is going to be a a v a
matrix of where each row is
a a sentence and then each there's like
the number of rows is the number of
batches in that training set and we're
going to Output a shape uh that's just
like for each for each row we want to
say is it does it match does it not
match so it's just going to be one one
choice
um yeah so I went ahead and trained that
and uh trained pretty well the numbers
went down so one thing about Caris is
it's got all the boiler plate for being
able to train your models without having
to write these complicated training
functions you just say model.fit uh
input data output data batch size number
of epo to fit it for and then some uh
random other stuff uh call back in this
case uh once the error is below a
certain threshold uh stop
training and let's uh plot the error or
the loss function so it goes down almost
to zero which is what we want um numbers
going down and uh yeah so our
model learns to we learn to model this
this data pretty well
and the interesting part is let's figure
out what it paid attention to
so that's what these
are uh so given
a giving given a a sentence or a
question is it wearing the shoes and we
have a answer the Cat in the Hat is in
the barn so is that wearing the shoes no
it's wearing the hat and
actually what happened is the the it it
decides not to pay attention to the word
hat like the attention on hat is very
small whereas so that's that's not a
match so is it wearing the shoes where
the answer is the cat in the shoes is in
the barn the attention on shoes is very
high well so everything else kind of
stays the same but the difference is it
pays attention to hat in this case or
doesn't pay attention to hat does pay
attention to shoes in this
case and uh yeah if you're if you uh go
on GitHub you can kind of uh kind of
figure out patterns from from what this
is
doing
so yeah
um that was basically a very very fast
introduction to all deep learning up to
about a year ago I think this is sort of
outdated now but I don't know there's
the paper that I based this off was like
published a year ago
so so very very fast but hopefully
everyone got something out of
it any question oh um if you wanna if
you want to actually
uh like look up I wrote a big blog post
about all this stuff which you can
see
I think I linked to it from the
presentation but um it's kind of got all
this stuff in Greater detail there's two
papers actually uh this one and this
one
what oh sure
uh the uh the authors were all from IBM
actually so kind of
coincidence uh this paper so the first
paper was applying deep learning to
answer selection to study an open task
so this is kind of a classic NLP
question like given a question and an
answer choose and a set of answers
choose the best answer it's like exactly
what Google does um has this list of
documents and has a query and tries to
figure out which documents best match
the query um and this paper did that
using if you
can uh this paper did that using uh
convolutional neural networks which are
just another type of neural network that
are very popular and um and this paper
this other paper did that using
lstms uh with the tensional components
built into them so given a given a
question if you have this intentional
component added on it makes it easier to
separate the good answers from the bad
answers
yeah so that's pretty much as I was only
planning on talking for like 90 minutes
but kind of because of flight issues got
switched around
[Applause]
so
questions
uh I think B and Joe is the guy who did
both of them the pi for
both uh these are both on AR Arch
archive but I guess iclr
and um do do I have time left or I could
uh could show you had to put it on so
like running these models on my laptop
doesn't work very well because it's not
very fast but
um uh you can put them on Amazon web
services or Google compute engine um
those are both good options for running
complicated models in the
cloud
uh I happened to have uh one of my
professors had a credit for Google
compute engine
so
oops
oh I changed my phone number recently so
this probably doesn't work
actually yeah I'm pretty sure it doesn't
work so I'm pretty sure I'm locked out
of my account oh
well
H oh yeah but I changed my phone number
so I I think it you know new phone and
all doesn't send it to the right
phone well I'll tell you what it would
happen uh basically you
can if you want to check out the other
uh repo that uh actually it's got like a
lot of the stuff implemented for a real
life task it's this repository right
here
uh code Kansas SL Car- language-
modeling
um and it's got kind of I've got
instructions on here for how to put it
how to get deployed on a gole Google
Cloud platform in since um there's like
an install
script
um and this was actually trained on real
data uh this was basically was copying
the the paper used here um to train it
on some real
data and uh the moral of of that story
was lstms take a really really long time
to train um unless you have you know B
gpus so if anyone
yeah right yeah you have a a sample set
of of answers in this case the loss
function you calculate embeddings for a
good answer and a bad answer and the
loss function
is you subtract the good answer and you
add the bad answer or the similarity
between the good answer and the question
and you add the similarity between the
bad answer in the question so to to make
that go down you want the similarity
between the good answer and the question
to go up and the similarity between the
bad answering the question to go down or
yeah
oh yeah no it's uh it does generalize
pretty well like you have a a testing
set um the data set here is like split
into there's like three different
testing sets and um it got like in the
paper it got like 60% top one accuracy
which is really good uh if you think
about like all the all the possible
answers there's like one or two good
answers and it picked those out of you
know 500 candidate answers um 60% of the
time it gets the best one as its Top
Choice
um yeah you uh I mean there I think
there's been some work on like
generating questions too um
yeah so who's
like who who thinks they'll use car us
at some point in the
future
nice hopefully uh yeah you can get get
involved with the Google Google group
there's like a pretty active community
on there and um yeah there more more or
less
[Applause]
it
yeah yeah a lot of it uh a lot a lot of
the stuff that's going on right now is
kind of starts with Caris because it's
really easy to get your model up and
testing it so to be able to modify Caris
to do stuff you want to do is really
important because if you want to try a
new network it's a lot easier to have
all the basic stuff down so you can just
try the interesting stuff um the
generative stuff
um like there's ways to do it in Caris
uh like you basically set
up this kind of network where you
generate a
sequence it's pretty pretty pretty easy
to
do the the generative adversarial
networks is hot right now um there was
someone who wrote A implementation of
that in
Caris
um
yeah it's not in this repository but uh
other people have it for
sure I mean yeah it's a it's a very
popular framework right now I think
behind tensorflow and Cafe it's the most
popular way to do deep learning and it's
a lot easier than either of those two in
my opinion
so yeah
awesome thanks
very
[Applause]
you